[Music]
hi everyone hope you've been enjoying
the day one of the summits so far I'm
parle sory and part of the Google Play
team and I'm said on the android
framework team before we head out to
lunch we just want to take a few minutes
to talk to you about something pretty
important privacy specifically we want
to talk to you about certain practices
that US app developers can adopt to
build products that continue to wow your
users at the same time protect their
right to privacy we want Android to be a
platform where you can offer
personalized experiences and make the
life of your users simple but at the
same time privacy is important and
transparency in terms of what data
you're collecting and how you're using
it is very important to be shared so to
ensure Android can continue to serve as
a platform but allows developers to
build such experiences and protect users
we have ongoing efforts that span
multiple releases so the females want to
touch upon today are how your apps are
accessing user data ensuring that your
users have control over of data being
accessed and most importantly a very
transparency into why the data is
required and how it is being used so we
have a multi-layered approach to privacy
in Android firstly we focus on platform
updates to improve the api's that are
used by apps to access personal
information we then set up our Play
policies for keeping abusing check and
also ensuring that a level playing field
is provided to the developers and a safe
experience for our users we've built how
at another layer to identify early on
when apps may be abusing a user's
personal information we also have human
reviewers so it's not just BOTS in AI
but actual people who review these apps
to make sure that the users right to
privacy is as always is always secured
and also ensured that the safe
experience is provided we also invest
heavily in secure to walk with a
community of security researchers please
do check out these programs we have the
Play security rewards program and
vulnerability rewards programs and also
feel free to drop by if you want to know
more about these and finally we have
Google Play protects which helps you
which helps users conserve their privacy
one security doing that sighs so why are
we here speaking to you today because we
feel privacy and security is a
partnership between the platform and
developers as you u.s. developers who
actually below these apps say a very
vital role in the ecosystem you have the
ability to advocate for better privacy
practices in your company and ways to
ensure that the team's vision of your
product is not compromised at the right
of users privacy for example if you have
a request to sort to collect certain bit
of information about a user from their
device a question always worth asking is
do we really need it how do you plan to
use it and are we still using it in the
instances of historical data collection
the reason is that it is actually not
very uncommon for certain information
about a user to be collected in guides
of behavioral analytics which is
actually never used and is sometimes
abandoned altogether so some example
data where we seen being collected
includes I me I used as a unique
identifier for tracking users the list
of installed apps over to fingerprint a
user or to target ads to them collecting
the location of an app open or Solano
net network information such as the name
of a network over strength
you probably don't always need such
information so for a few cases we offer
more privacy conscious options so
encourage you to use them if they fit
your use case
some examples include we encourage you
to use instance for Android ID instead
of a hardware device such as IMEI if
you're trying to confirm that users
phone number we encourage you to use a
Play SMS receiver API instead of the SMS
permission which is not as granular you
could also consider only requesting
qualification instead of throwing fine
location and then if you want to see if
it usually is in a call you could check
for the audio focus rather than
requesting a read phone state which
gives out a lot more data
and lastly you want to ensure that your
users are aware of what data is being
collected and how it has been used this
is not just a best practice but is
actually a requirement by Google say
policy a rule of thumb is that if the
user is not aware that some data about
them is about to be collected and for
what purpose it has been used you are
required to prominently disclose it to
them and get their permission to do so
so the example that we have here the
data is being collected off the
installed apps on a user's device for
fraud prevention purposes so this needs
to be prominently disclosed to the user
and only after your user consents to it
should the data be transferred so in the
latest Android releases we've worked
heart of a more privacy sensitive OS I'm
gonna walk you through a few of us
changes so in Android 9 we split up the
core lock permissions from the phone
permission group into their own
permission group core log to give users
more transparency into what apps are
doing so if your app is requesting phone
reading phone numbers from the phone's
state broadcast change we're now asking
you to request both fork or log and with
phone state permissions in Android 8 we
defecated the build Co static field
replacing it with a bill that gets your
function that requires a read phone
state permission if you're going to use
it please be sure you can use it for
valid purposes because it's applied
policy violation choose it for
advertising purposes
speaking of limited access a reminder
apps running in the background on
Android 9.0 will require the following
restrictions you will no longer have
access to mic or camera in the
background sensors such as accelerometer
gyroscope will return empty data if your
app needs access to sensor events on
devices running Android 9.0 you will
need to use a foreground service and to
further inform and protect the user the
system will also add a visual aid to
your notifications when your services
are accessing the camera or the mic so a
contacts provider API used to allow apps
to constitute data about how often a
contact was being contacted allowing
other apps
to believe information about
interactions not happening within their
own scope so as of January next year a
limited set of contact fields and
methods will be made obsolete
these include fields relating to the
last time a contact was accessed or
contacted so if your app is accessing or
updating these fields we ask you to use
alternative methods for example you
could fulfill certain use cases by using
private content providers or simply
storing data in your back-end systems so
this was a really brief talk about best
practices for privacy we hope that he
been able to offer you at least some
insight into how you can build apps that
are conscious of users right to privacy
and also compliant with all our policies
so as we've mentioned earlier we
definitely believe that security and
privacy is a partnership between you the
developer and our platform so if you
have any questions about it please do
come find us at the office hours and I
hope you all have a great summit and
have a great lunch as well thank you so
much thank you
[Music]